- Drag the lines up or down.
Order them from longest to shortest.
Put the longest line on top.
So, alright, out of these three lines,
the longest one is this one.
So, I click on this
and I move it to the top.
And they want us to order
from longest to shortest.
So, we want the longest on top,
and the shortest on the bottom
and the medium one in the middle.
And, that's what we have.
Longest, less long and the least long,
or the shortest, right over there.
Let's keep going.
Alright.
Is it taller or shorter?
So, let's see this whale,
even if we don't count the water
that's coming out of its spout,
is taller than these three blocks.
So, I would say,
the whale is taller than three blocks.
If I said the whale is
shorter than three blocks
it wouldn't make sense.
'Cause a whale is more
than three blocks tall.
So, it's taller than the three blocks.
The squirrel is, well,
the squirrel is clearly shorter
than the three blocks.
It looks like it's about two blocks tall.
So, the squirrel is shorter
than the two blocks.
You scroll down because
there's another question.
So, the whale is blank the squirrel.
Well, the whale's gonna be taller
than the squirrel,
and you can see that if
you just compare the whale
straight to the squirrel,
or you can say, "look,
if the whale is more
"than three blocks,
"the whale is taller than three blocks,
"the squirrel is shorter
than three blocks,
"so the whale must be
taller than the squirrel."
Because the whale is
taller than the blocks
which are taller than the squirrel.
So, the whale is gonna be
taller than the squirrel.
Let's keep going.
Is it taller or shorter?
The cookie is shorter
than these five blocks.
The ice cream cone is, well it looks,
it's taller than the five blocks.
So, the cookie is, well,
the cookie's shorter than the five blocks
which is shorter than the ice cream cone.
The ice cream cone is
taller than the blocks
which are taller than the cookie.
So, the cookie is, for sure,
shorter than the ice cream cone.
It's shorter than this
which is shorter than the ice cream cone.
So, it's definitely shorter
than the ice cream cone.
Let's do one more.
Is it taller or shorter?
Well, the penguin is taller
than the four blocks.
The turtle is shorter than the 10 blocks,
sorry, the four blocks.
The penguin is taller than four blocks.
The turtle is shorter than four blocks.
So, the penguin is, well,
it's gonna be taller than a turtle.
The penguin is taller than the blocks
which are taller than the turtle.
So, the penguin is taller than the turtle.
Lots of fun.